introducing BMW sixth generation seven
series it's due to hit showroom floors
this autumn
in this vehicle class evolution rather
than revolution is the name of the game
that said there are some obvious
innovations in the design any new model
inevitably boasts a few technical
novelties in this case they include
laser and LED lighting and aerodynamic
air intakes
production has also been revamped in
recent years lightweight engineering and
design is ubiquitous in the car industry
not least because it helps reduce carbon
emissions but it comes in various shapes
and sizes varying from one car maker to
another high tensile steel aluminium and
plastic parts have become fairly
standard but BMW is going one step
further with its new seven series thanks
to new methods carbon fiber body parts
can now be manufactured for large-scale
production not just the visible parts
are made of costly carbon fiber as with
the i8 this time it also features in the
chassis even though it's out of sight
yeah Harold Kruger from BMW explains
that over half a billion euros was
invested in these new technologies over
the last three years the plant in dingle
thing has been refining manufacturing
and its competence in making superior
series makes it an ideal place to
produce the 7-series the lightweight
construction isn't just environmentally
friendly it also enhances the driving
experience there's less centrifugal
force around bends which combined with
intelligent construction makes the new
seventh series almost as agile as the
3-series but a lot more luxurious
the interior also features innovative
technology it's super user friendly
maximising comfort in the back seat is a
built-in tablet holder hit a button and
you can remove it and take it with you
when you slot it back in it's
automatically secured this allows you to
control all the main driving functions
as well as the in-car entertainment
system the seats in the back can of
course be adjusted
yeah as Klaus foolish explains further
highlights include semi autonomous
driving technology for speeds of up to
210 km/h remote-controlled parking
world-first and efficient dynamics Moya
highlights but in for poison of burning
fossil fuel consumption for the plug-in
hybrid BMW 740 II is rated at 2.1 liters
per 100 kilometers with co2 emissions of
49 grams per kilometer as with its
predecessor the new seven series comes
with a choice of two wheelbases it's
also available with all-wheel drive the
3-litre diesel version of the new Beemer
will set you back 82 thousand euros the
750li starts at one hundred and thirteen
thousand euros in Germany the frills
cost extra needless to say
you